Black:
Hi, my name is Naomi Black.
I'm a member of the
Accessibility Engineering team
at Google,
and I work
on captioning for YouTube,
and I also work on accessibility
for the blind.
Boedihardjo:
Hi, I'm Cynthia Boedihardjo.
I am a livestream
program manager at Google.
And I work on different types
of livestreams
from concerts
to this year's Google I/O.
Posnick: And I'm Jeff Posnick,
and I'm a member of the YouTube
API Developer Relations team
at Google.
Black: So before we get started,
I want to point out
the hashtags if you feel the
need to tweet during our talk--
#io2011 and #youtube.
There's a link for feedback.
And if you want to talk to us
afterwards about captioning
and stuff related to this talk,
send an email
to captioning@google.com,
and it will reach us.
So I thought I'd start
by giving you an overview
of what we're gonna talk about
in our talk.
I'm gonna start by introducing
the captioning
that we did here at I/O Live,
which was streamed
from the conference,
and talk about that
a little bit.
And Cynthia will talk to you
about how the gadget
was created
and what that involved.
And then we will talk
about WebVTT,
which is a new timed text format
for HTML5.
It lets us do some cool things,
and we'll show you some demos
in WebKit and some code.
And then Jeff will talk
about the YouTube Caption API,
and there will be more code
and demos.
So I'd like to start
by talking a little bit
about why captions
are important to us.
This chart, which--
you can't read it.
Just notice that there are bars
and some of them are larger
than the others.
[laughs]
The really long bars--
so these
are the world population
on the Internet roughly
by country.
And at the top we have China.
There's lots of Chinese.
And then there's
the United States,
and it goes down the list.
And you can see
there's some yellow bars.
And the first yellow bar
represents the number
of deaf
and hard of hearing people
in the United States alone.
And so that number--
I like to throw this out
because I'm Canadian.
That's more than the population
of Canada that's online.
So, you know, nobody would say,
"Oh, well, let's not,"
you know,
"let's not broadcast this
to the Canadians.
They could care less."
But sometimes,
when we put video online,
if it doesn't have captions,
you're excluding a population
that's actually larger
than that.
So I like to throw this graph up
to really show you the numbers.
So we caption our videos
for accessibility reasons
obviously,
but captions and timed text
are actually really powerful
for the web because video
is really hard to search.
But when you caption your video,
the full text of that video,
if you upload captions
to YouTube,
that full text
becomes searchable.
So you can actually search
inside your video
on something that was said
at minute 30
that may not be in your talk
description or your title.
Captioned video,
because the captions are text,
we can do cool things with it.
We can change the size.
We can translate the captions
using machine translation.
And our audience
on the Internet
doesn't necessarily speak
our language.
We really--
we want to reach the world.
So captions are helpful
for translation.
And finally
there's a lot of people
who use
same language subtitling.
They may be learning
your language.
And so having the text
underneath the speaker
helps them follow an accent
that's unfamiliar
or somebody who's speaking
faster than they're used to.
And I'd like
to show this picture.
This was taken at a conference
that we had
in France recently
called Atmosphere.
And this is CIOs and CTOs
and businesspeople.
Nobody was wearing a T-shirt.
And they all met in France,
but they spoke English.
And very few of the attendees
had English as a first language,
but it was the common language
that everybody came
to do business in.
And so to help our attendees,
even though there was nobody
at this conference
who was deaf
or hard of hearing
as far as I know,
we presented the text on screen
in all of the talks
behind the speaker
so that everybody
who was coming together
and using this language
that was unfamiliar to them
would have the assistance
of the text.
You think about developers
in Japan.
They're very used
to reading English,
but maybe not as used
to hearing it spoken,
especially for technical terms.
So these captions
really help everyone.
So at I/O this year,
we have live captions.
We actually had live captions
last year,
but this year we decided
to go a step further
with the huge interest
in I/O Live
for the streaming video.
We really wanted to accompany
the video with captions
and make those available
not just here at I/O
but for the world.
So I'm gonna talk a little bit
about what that involved.
The first thing I need to tell
people is that captions are done
by people.
I mean, not all captions.
We have automatic captions
on YouTube,
but the kinds of captions
that you're seeing here
at I/O where they're popping up
on screen
several hundred words a minute,
we don't have computers that
are fast and accurate enough
to do that,
and so we rely
on highly-skilled people
who are typing
on special stenography rig,
and that allows them to go
several hundred words a minute
very accurately,
and that then goes out
to the screen on the show floor,
and, in this case,
you can see Laura.
She's one
of our transcriptionists.
This picture was actually taken
on the first keynote.
And she's typing away
on her rig.
And that's sending
the captions out.
Beyond the show floor,
we send them by TCP/IP,
and they go out
through a service,
in this case provided
by a company called StreamText,
and they had a .NET connector,
and they provide
the streaming service
for accessibility
to the Web.
Well, when we came to them
and we wanted
to do this for I/O,
we realized
we were gonna have
a lot of people watching
this caption gadget,
and so we wanted
to really host it
on App Engine for scalability.
So I went to Cynthia,
and Cynthia's gonna talk
about what was involved.
Boedihardjo: Thanks, Naomi.
So I don't know
if you guys have been keeping up
with what's going on
with YouTube,
but there have been
a lot of requests
for live streaming events.
So as of early April,
we actually launched
YouTube.com/live,
which will show you a whole
bunch of different live events
that our YouTube partners
are hosting.
With the live events,
some of them kind of include
product launches,
concerts,
like, John Legend in concert,
sporting events
like IPL,
which, you know, garners,
like, 50 million views
as of last year,
and then, of course,
this year's Google I/O.
As the increase of live events
come on YouTube,
we've noticed
that some of these events
include
these informational talks
where there's a lot of speech
that's going on.
And we have a lot
of non-English viewers,
as well as, you know,
just people
who might not really be able
to understand
somebody speaking very--
very fast.
So what we wanted to do
was create a gadget
that not only had the captions
underneath the live player
but had the ability
to also translate
in real time.
So what we did was,
in order to build
the caption gadget,
we contracted the help
of Psycle Interactive,
which is this UK company
and independent production house
that we've worked with
on YouTube many times,
as well as StreamText,
which is a real-time
streaming text provider.
For the gadget, our requirements
were pretty simple.
One, we wanted to take
the real-time text
from StreamText and feed it
into the gadget;
two, translate it in real time
in multiple languages
and use Google Translate API;
and, of course, make the code
open source,
which means
not only can you use this
on YouTube live events
if you're a partner,
but you can also use this
for other, you know,
live--live events
that you may be doing
on other sites.
Or even if you wanted to do it--
use it for something else,
you could essentially just take
that code.
So I don't know
if you guys have been able
to see what the gadget
actually looks like.
But let me just show you.
It's on the Web site--
the Google I/O homepage.
Black:
Do you want the sound off?
Boedihardjo: Yeah, let me
just make sure it's muted here.
But essentially what it does
is it takes in a real-time feed
from StreamText, so the ladies
who are actually transcribing--
takes in what's coming in
from the stage.
And because
usually during a live stream
there's a five
to ten-second delay,
we added a feature
in the gadget
to add a delay depending on,
like, if you're doing
just one event, maybe
the speaker speaks super fast,
you might want to put
a one-second delay in there
versus, like, a two-second.
Right now, we have,
like, a two-second delay
on all of our streams.
But essentially the features
that we added in here
were the ability
to take in that real-time text.
It's all hosted on App Engine,
so we actually had
to make a special request
and have
the App Engine team provision,
you know, a lot of bandwidth
for us
so that we can take in
all these requests from users,
and I'll share some stats
with you later on today.
And with Google Translate,
we have the ability
to translate this
into 57 languages.
So let me just demo...
let's do Croatian.
What it does--
it takes a couple of seconds,
and then it'll translate
to Croatian super fast.
So what it does is--usually
for the English translation,
it's word for word,
but because we wanted
Google Translate
to translate the context
of the actual speech,
we wait 35 characters.
I don't know if anybody here
speaks Croatian, but--
Black: I saw
somebody actually tweeted
that they were watching it
in Hindi.
Boedihardjo:
Oh, cool.
Black: I don't speak Hindi,
but they tweeted about it.
Boedihardjo: So those are some
of the features we had.
So some of the technical
challenges were, you know,
how are we gonna handle
the viewership.
App Engine helped us with that,
as well as that delay
that I had mentioned.
Here are some stats
that we got from just yesterday.
Vic had mentioned, you know,
there were 600 viewers
to the stream.
There was actually 250 viewers
to that captioning gadget
itself.
Black: Thousand.
Boedihardjo: 250,000 viewers.
Sorry.
I like to shorten things.
The top five countries--
or the top five languages
people selected were English,
Spanish, Portuguese,
French, and Russian.
And then out
of the 57 languages
that Google Translate had
the ability to translate into,
52 languages
were actually selected,
which is kind
of an amazing number.
So you're probably wondering,
if you wanted to use
this gadget,
how to go about doing that.
We made the code available.
We'll make this PDF open
to you guys after the session.
So just follow that link
for Google code
and you can get it there.
As well,
if you are a YouTube partner,
especially a live partner,
go ahead and speak
to your Google or YouTube rep,
and you can ask them
how to go about using this
for your next event.
I'll go back to Naomi,
and she can talk to you
about WebVTT.
Black: Thanks, Cynthia.
So we've been talking
about captioning,
but you notice on this slide
I've changed the term
to timed text.
And so I'm gonna explain to you
why we're not just talking
about captioning anymore.
So timed text encompasses
much more than just captioning.
It encompasses any use of text
that's useful for video
where there's a time component
that's important to us.
So people who are
hard of hearing or deaf,
they're gonna need captions
to understand the context
of the video,
but people who are blind
are also using a form
of timed text
called audio description.
And traditional
audio description--
if you go look
on YouTube, actually,
there's a talk on WebVTT
that we gave a few weeks ago,
and you can find there's
an audio description version.
So audio description
is the process
of creating a new script
for a video that includes
all of the visual elements
that somebody who's blind might
not have available to them.
So you might think about taking
something like this talk
and putting it online.
Well, a blind user can listen
to everything they're saying,
so they must be getting
everything, right?
But they're not gonna get
that slide that I put up
with the bars that actually
none of you could see either,
but they wouldn't be able
to see Cynthia's talk--
the part of her demo, and so
what audio description does
is it provides this information
in a script that's written out,
and the script has time cues,
and it says,
at this moment,
describe, you know,
the slide on screen
shows a pie chart and,
you know, and so on.
So audio description is useful
for blind users,
and it has a text
and a time component.
You can use synchronization
for music lyrics.
You can do your own karaoke.
And navigation
is very helpful.
You think about what we're able
to do today
on our DVD players
where you can just cue ahead
through chapters.
It would be great
if you could do that on YouTube
and just say, "Oh, you know,
I want to jump ahead
to the more interesting part
of this talk."
So HTML5 has a text-based
solution for all of these.
It's called--well, actually,
HTML5 under the video element
has a track element
that accommodates timed text.
HTML5 doesn't recommend
a particular format.
You can support any format
that you like,
and so, in this case,
we're proposing a format
called WebVTT.
And I'm gonna show you
some demos in WebKit
that show that support.
So here's an example file
in the WebVTT format,
and in WebVTT we have things
that we'll call cues.
And so a cue is basically
some text that has a start time
and an end time.
So in this case you can see
there's a start time point
and then there's
an end time point.
And then below it
there's some text
that is appearing on screen
between those two time points.
And you can see
that we've marked this up
with simple HTML styling.
We have support for italics
and bold
and underline.
And so then the next line,
I've actually got--
you have positioning
that we can specify as well.
So I can say t percentage, 60%.
And if you look, the center line
of the captions on there--
it's a little hard to see,
but the captions
on the center line are
a little off from the center.
We position them
over to the side.
And we can set a line position
as well.
So I can very accurately,
using WebVTT,
pinpoint exactly
where on the screen
I want that text to appear.
And that's useful.
If you watch captions on TV,
you'll see that people
use text positioning
to identify sometimes
who is speaking.
So you have
two people speaking,
the captions appear on the left,
you know it's that person
who's speaking.
The person on the right speaks,
the captions move.
Today, if you look at YouTube,
we don't have
that capability, and so we're
looking ahead at the Web.
We want the Web
to offer everything
that our TV captions do,
maybe even more.
And so positioning is
a really important part of that.
So here's
another WebVTT example file.
Because WebVTT is on the Web,
we really want to use
the richness of CSS and HTML,
so in this case I have
to find a pseudo element
inside my queue.
I have C. arduino,
and you can see the CSS
from my page
then specifies how that
arduino cue should be styled,
and so I've set the color
to be red
and the text to be uppercase.
And this is really interesting
to me.
One of my responsibilities
at Google
is making sure that our content
is captioned,
and I speak to a lot
of YouTube partners,
and we see
more and more TV content
that's moving to the Web.
Well, if I'm watching "Dr. Who"
in Britain,
I'm going to see my captions
according
to UK caption standards.
So individual speakers will have
their text styled
in different colors.
Whenever I see blue text,
maybe that's
the Doctor speaking.
And I would just recognize
and expect that.
But here in the United States,
we're used to seeing our
captions all in the same color.
And they're styled
a little bit differently.
So currently what happens,
if I'm the BBC and I want
to provide that video file,
I have to make
my caption file twice.
I have to make it once
for the UK styling
and once
for the American styling
and again for any other region
that I'm distributing to
that has a different look
and feel for captions.
But with CSS you could see
how I could create
a single caption file that marks
things up semantically,
and then I could use CSS
on my Web page
to style it differently
depending on who's watching it.
I'm gonna gloss over this slide
pretty quickly.
I just want to indicate this
is allowing us to do Chinese
and Japanese characters.
We have full UTF-8 support
in WebVTT,
so unlike many broadcast formats
where the text
has to be rasterized
to represent double-byte,
in this case it just stays
as text within the file.
And because it stays as text,
we can translate that text
and we can search on that text,
and for the Web
that's really important.
So here's an example
of the caption--
the type of captions that--
sorry, let me step back.
Here's an example
of the video element in HTML5.
So I've been talking
about the format.
Let me tell you
a little bit more
about how you would represent
this in HTML5.
So the video element
in HTML5 says,
"Okay, here's my video element,"
and then underneath it
I have a source element
for the video file
that tells me where to find
the video that I'm gonna play.
And then I have a bunch
of track elements,
and these track elements here--
you'll notice I have
two different types of tracks.
I have a captions track
and I have a subtitle track.
And so the subtitle track,
that would be just the text.
Like, if you're watching
a French movie
and you see just the text
that's appearing,
it doesn't represent any of the
noises or the background sounds
that a user who's deaf
might be relying on,
whereas captions include
often in square brackets
things like laughter
or applause.
So we have two different kinds--
we have captions and subtitles.
And when I set the kind
to be caption or subtitle,
what happens in the players,
the player then says,
"Oh, this is for me.
I should display this as text,
as captions on screen."
So I'm gonna show you a demo
of that.
So what I'm running here
is Chromium.
And I have--I have
a very new build of Chromium.
We literally got the first
implementation support
of some of these things
in the last week.
So if you install Chromium
today, you won't see this,
but we're hoping, by the time
we've unit-tested everything
and we've checked everything
and made sure
that it's really solid,
hopefully by the end
of the summer or early fall
you'll be able to see these
as well.
And because these things
are gonna be baked into WebKit,
they'll be available in any
browser that supports WebKit.
So you as the video provider,
you don't have to create
a new player
every time you want
to include a video
and make it accessible.
Okay.
So here I am in Chromium.
I'm gonna play my video.
Can we turn the sound on?
Schepers: ...all right?
Black: Can we turn
the sound down a bit?
[laughter]
Okay, that was
a little scary.
Let me go again.
Schepers: So I just wanted to...
Black: So here we have--
he's speaking,
there's text underneath.
You can see it's styled
with italics.
And I can change the caption
language here with the selector.
This selector
is using JavaScript,
but eventually this feature
would be built into the player.
So let's make them German.
Schepers:
...introduce you to W3C and...
Black: And this is
not machine translation here.
Let me show you
the index file.
Here's the index file.
Okay, so here you see
this is the same thing
that I showed you on my slide.
We have a video track.
We have the source--
with the video element
we have the source element,
and then here we have
two track elements,
one for English
and one for German.
And that's what I'm playing
here in my video
in the demo.
So let me show you
what the WebVTT looks like,
and just to prove to you
that I'm really doing this live,
I'm gonna make a change to it.
So I'm gonna open this
with TextMate.
So this is really simple,
right?
I'm editing this
in a text editor.
I don't need a fancy tool--
although, if I'm doing
lots of these,
a fancy tool might be helpful.
I can just go
in any text editor,
and here I'm gonna change
these italics
to be underlined.
And I'm gonna save my file.
I'm gonna go back
and reload my page.
Uhh...
Did I reload it?
Let me try that again.
Okay, so let's play the video
and see if it's picked up
my change.
So now you can see that change
that I made is right away
reflected in the video.
And it's the player
that's doing that.
It's WebKit that's handling
all of the code to do that.
The HTML at my end
is really simple.
So let's go back
to the slides.
Okay, so audio description--
I was mentioning
how audio description is helpful
to people who are blind.
I'm gonna show you a demo
that demonstrates
how you can use just plain text
and send it to the speech
synthesis on your computer
in order to render
audio description,
so normally you would have
to do a video production step
where you have a file--
that you have a wav file
that you then mix in
with video production,
and that can add a lot
to both your cost
and the time it takes you
to produce something.
But what if you could just
type that out and provide it
just like you provide
a text transcript
and rely on the screen reader
on your computer to do it.
So let me show you
how that works.
So I'm gonna go back
into Chromium.
And I'm gonna go turn on
ChromeVox.
I don't know if you were
in the earlier talk on Chrome.
ChromeVox is the extension
for Chrome
that we released this week,
and it's basically
a screen reader for ChromeVox.
So in this case
actually let me go show you this
in the slides again.
In this case,
the kind is description.
'Cause when I set the kind
to be description,
then the player in HTML5
knows that it's not supposed
to render this
as text on screen;
it's supposed to play it
through speech.
So you can see it's, again:
start time, end time,
and then some text.
So let's go into Chromium.
Okay, I've turned ChromeVox on.
Hopefully, the sound is on.
male voice: Blender,
"Elephants Dream" tab.
Black: So that's ChromeVox
telling me the tab is open.
And I'm gonna hit play
and see what happens.
So the audio description
should be describing the video,
the visual elements
on the screen,
and it should be doing it
using the screen reader voice
that's already on my computer.
So let's see how that works.
You know what,
let me refresh my page.
I bet it's not talking
to ChromeVox yet.
One sec.
male voice: Blender,
"Elephants Dream."
Black: Okay, now it should know
that it has ChromeVox.
Let's try this.
male voice: The Orange open
movie project presents...
Black: So that's
audio description for my video
that's been provided
by a WebVTT file.
And I can even go in
and quickly change this.
I'm gonna say the...
awesome Orange open movie
project presents...
and let's go refresh the page.
male voice: Blender,
"Elephants Dream."
The awesome Orange open movie
project presents...
Boedihardjo: Cool.
Black: So that was much easier
than having to go
into the studio and record
a wav file
and then mix it in
and wait
for the video to render.
This is, like, really fast
on the fly.
So my next example
is to show you
how we can do chapters
using kind="chapters".
In this case, when
my track element in WebVTT
is provided
with kind="chapters",
then it knows
that what it's supposed to do
is use this to enable some kind
of navigation.
And I'm kind of hand-waving here
because we haven't built
the full support
into WebKit yet,
although we're going
in this direction.
What I'm going to show you today
involves using JavaScript
to do the same thing.
male voice: Demos for Nao...
navigation using...
Black: Okay, so imagine that we
don't have the screen reader on
and you're looking at this
as a sighted user.
You can see that there's a handy
navigation pane down the side.
And it's got a bunch
of text that tells you
each of the slides
that's available
and what they're about,
and I can go click on them.
And so when I click on it,
it jumps directly
to that part of the video.
And that's done--my page itself
is very simple.
This is just done by pulling
from the WebVTT file
and looking at what's
in this particular track.
But for a user who's blind,
we can have the same thing.
male voice:
Navigation using WebVTT...
Demo 3--HTML5 video acc--
Black: So I'm just hitting
Ctrl-Alt-down arrow to move
through the fields in this.
male voice: Introduct--HTML5--
Play video--Button.
Black: So now I'm
on the play button.
I'm gonna go down one more.
male voice: Title slide.
Press enter to navigate,
space to toggle play.
Black:
And so it says title slide
because Slide 1: Title Slide
is what exists
in my WebVTT file.
Let me just show it
to you quickly
to make that really clear.
And you can see it says
start time, end time,
title slide, and that's what
my screen reader is reading out.
So here, going back
to my demo then...
male voice: Title slide,
press enter to navigate.
[speaking rapidly]
Black: I can--
male voice: Press enter
to navigate,
space to toggle play.
Black: So as a blind user,
I can navigate
and jump between the sections
in my video
without having to see anything
that's on the screen.
So I'm gonna hit space to play.
male voice: A multimedia slide
presentation is titled
"HTML5 video accessibility
and the WebVTT..."
Black: And what
you're actually hearing there
is the the audio description
that we recorded
in the studio,
but you get the idea.
I have this fully-featured
navigation that's implemented
through WebKit and JavaScript.
And in the future, this kind
of support will just be baked
into the player.
One of the stumbling blocks
for us that we're still trying
to figure out is, how should
we really represent this?
What should it look like?
So this navigation bar
that you're seeing
is sort of our first guess
along the way
in terms of what kind
of implementation
we might want the user interface
to look like.
Okay, so going back
to the slides,
very quickly some JavaScript
examples just to show
how easy it is to do stuff.
Here I'm going,
and I have a four loop
that's going and looking
through the number of tracks
that I have;
it's picking out the ones
that are subtitles,
and then it chooses the one
that's French,
and it specifically turns on the
French captions in the player.
So you could use this
within the context of a page
to do stuff
like my language selector,
or you could do
more complex things.
And the next example shows
how you can register
an event handler
on all of your cue changes.
So any time text appears
or disappears
or is enabled or disabled,
you could pop up an alert
or you could do something
more elaborate.
But this is just a single line
of code.
So for the future
of media on the Web,
we're really excited
about WebVTT, and in part
we're excited about it because
it's a fairly simple format.
It's a simple format for
somebody who's creating content
to use and author.
But it's also fairly simple
in terms of what a browser needs
to support
in order to enable
sort of the full range
of features that are available
today in broadcast captions
and then go beyond it with some
of the richness of the Web
through CSS and JavaScript.
So if you're interested
in more on WebVTT,
if you go look on
the Google Developers Channel,
there's a video in two versions,
audio described and not,
on WebVTT, and we'll have links
at the end of our talk.
Oh, and let me close
my Chromium window
or it will be talking--
male voice:
[speaking rapidly]
Black:
So Jeff's gonna talk
about the YouTube captions API
now.
Posnick: Okay.
Thanks, Naomi.
So I wanted to talk
about a topic
that's specifically relevant
for folks who want
to add captions
or interact with captions
on videos that are hosted
on YouTube
and do that
in a programmatic manner.
So YouTube has a larger Data API
which allows you to manipulate
a whole bunch
of YouTube objects
and get information about videos
and so on and so forth.
And one subset of the Data API
is the YouTube Captions API.
And that's what I'll be talking
about today.
You can think of the YouTube
Data API as a REST-ful API.
It's a way of interacting
with YouTube via HTTP requests.
And it has certain restrictions
on how you can interact
with the API.
There's authentication
that's needed
in order to do,
specifically with captions,
any sort of modification
and retrieval of caption tracks.
You need to prove
that you are the video's owner
via one
of our authentication mechanisms
in order
to manipulate this data.
And you just also need
a YouTube API Developer key,
which you could register for
at one of the links that we
provide at the end of the slide.
So we support a number
of different formats
for caption data and conversions
between different formats
when you're requesting
that data.
RealText, SAMI,
SubRip, SubViewer
are a few of the formats.
We also support submitting
a just chunk of text.
Ideally a chunk of text that
corresponds to the actual audio
in your video.
And we'll try to autosync that.
And when you request captions,
regardless of what format,
you uploaded the captions
and you can specify one
of two different formats
for getting them back.
And you do that using the FMT
parameter in your request URL.
And one format is srt,
which is the SubRip format,
and one format is sbv,
which is SubViewer.
And we'll go into an example
a little bit later
that shows
how you can request
a specific format
and interact
with the API in general.
So I mentioned that one of the
options for uploading captions
is using auto-synchronization.
And this in many ways
simplifies the process
of adding captions.
You might have a transcript
of the speech
in a given event,
but you don't necessarily
have time codes,
which are normally required
in a caption format.
You just might have it
as paragraphs of text.
So you submit that to us,
and we'll run some processing
on our servers and do our best
to match up the speech
that we hear in the video
with the text
that you provide for us.
And, you know,
this works great
if there's
a good correspondence
between the text
you're uploading
and the person who's speaking.
And we support
English and Japanese
as the source language
for the video right now.
So that's one end of things.
Kind of the other end of things
regarding speech recognition
is the Automatic Speech
Recognition tracks.
And these are things
that are available
on demand via the API
if you make a request
authenticated
as the video owner.
And what this track is
is basically something
that uses speech recognition
to just analyze
the speech in your video
and generate
a corresponding caption track.
So when you're interacting
with the Automatic Speech
Recognition
or ASR track via the API,
the way you identify it from,
you know, what might be
a number
of different caption tracks
that are available
for your YouTube video
is looking
for the yt:derived tag.
And we'll show an example
that makes use of that later.
But just keep that in mind.
And that--that will show
that that is the ASR track.
And English and Japanese
language are currently supported
for generating that track.
So I have a piece of demo code
that I wanted to show
for you guys,
and before I do that,
I wanted to tell you
a little bit about what
it's gonna do obviously.
So what we want to do
is take in a video ID
corresponding
to a YouTube video.
This is just a unique identifier
so we know
which YouTube video
we're operating on.
And we're going to retrieve
the ASR caption track
for that specific video,
we're gonna translate it
into Pig Latin,
and then we're gonna upload
that translation
as a new caption track
for that video.
So what we're--you're gonna see
is Python command line code.
It doesn't have to be Python
if you're doing interaction
with the YouTube Captions API.
Well, actually I have an example
a little bit later on
that uses Java,
but really anything
that could send HTTP requests
can be used to interact
with the Captions API.
And this Python command line
code is actually using
the new Google API Python
client library for handling
some of the authentication
that I mentioned is necessary.
And that actually makes things
a lot easier
for me as a developer and,
you know, for you guys as well
if you go out
and write some code.
So I definitely recommend that,
if there is a client library
available for the language
that you're programming in,
to take a look at using that,
'cause it'll simplify things.
And, you know, again, this is
a bit of a silly example,
but, you know, it's intended
to illustrate
how you could do retrieval,
processing, and then re-upload
of your own caption tracks,
and, you know, I'm sure
that--that folks have ideas
for, you know,
more meaningful things
that you could do.
So as I mentioned,
there's a few different steps
involved here.
The first thing
that our code is gonna do
is use OAuth 2 authentication
to request access
to your YouTube accounts.
And actually because I'm using
the Python client library,
I only have to do that once,
and that'll be--
excuse me, it'll cache
my authentication token
and reuse that
in subsequent requests,
which is great.
And just to clarify,
it's not caching,
like, my Google account's
email address
and password;
it's just a token
that gets returned
from the OAuth 2 service
and can be revoked
at any time.
So if you are writing
your own code
and you're allowing users
to authenticate for any purpose,
you know,
whether it's interacting
with the Captions API or
anything else that you're doing,
I highly recommend
using something like OAuth 2,
which is our recommended method,
or AuthSub or OAuth 1
for doing your authentication.
It's just something I think
your users will appreciate,
not having to enter
their credentials directly
into your application.
So that being said,
once we have the authentication
in place,
we're going to retrieve
the Automatic Speech Recognition
track for the given video.
That's done by interacting
with the YouTube API.
Then we have a little bit
of logic in place
in the coded self
for Pig Latin-ification
of the different text components
of that track.
And then once we've done that,
we're going to re-upload
the new track,
also using
the YouTube Captions API,
and it should be visible
on YouTube.
So before we get into that,
I want to bring up...
This is our source video
that we're gonna
be operating on here.
This is a video I took
of my son rolling over
for the first time.
This is my first day
home with you.
And you can see here,
this is the Automatic Speech
Recognition track
that was generated
for this video,
so that's
what we're starting with.
See, there's no other
caption tracks
that are currently available.
So this is the code
we're gonna be using.
It's available, you know,
as part of just the whole
collection of samples
that interact with
the YouTube API, so feel free
to check out the actual code.
I'm not gonna go
through everything here,
but, you know,
afterwards take a look
for yourself,
and I'm gonna go
through a few relevant sections.
So the first thing
that's important
in terms of interacting
with the YouTube API
is this method,
GetAsrTrackUrl.
What it's gonna do
is first generate
a specific URL.
Because this is a REST-ful API,
everything is identified
via URLs,
and it's plugging
in the video ID that's read
from the command line into a,
you know, well-defined format
for the captions track.
And this is something
that's gonna get
a list of all the captions
that are available
for a specific video,
assuming there are any.
So once we have that--
sorry, once we have that URL,
we're going to make an HTTP
request pointing out that URL,
and I'm just making use
of the fact
that the Python client library
can generate the necessary
authentication headers
from my request,
so again this is gonna be
an authenticated request.
Otherwise, it won't get back
the ASR caption track.
And once I look--
get the response,
take a look and make sure
there's a successful response--
in my URL I'm specifying
that I'd like to retrieve
the data back in JSON format,
the JavaScript Object Notation
format, which is very easy
to deserialize in Python,
and then to use
just normal Python methods
for interacting with that data.
So that's what I'm doing
right over here.
I'm calling json.loads(body)
and then I'm looping
through the response,
and I'm taking a look
at the different...
elements in the response.
I'm trying to find
the specific captions track
that has the yt:derive tag.
And since I keep skipping ahead
anyway,
let me just show you
what the relevant portion
of the response will look like.
So, you know,
has the yt:derive tag in it,
and then there's
a related content element,
but it has a source attribute
within that.
And that's the URL
for the specific caption track
that we're looking to get, so
it's kind of a two-step process.
First we have to get a list
of all the caption tracks
for a given video,
and we loop through them,
we find the specific caption
track that we're looking for,
and we get
that corresponding URL.
And that's what's going on
in that code.
And the next step,
once we have that URL,
we want to retrieve it again,
so we're making
another HTTP request.
This time
we're using that FMT parameter
that I talked about before.
So we take whatever the URL
that was returned
from our previous request,
we add on the FMT=srt parameter
so that we get back the captions
in the srt format.
And much like before,
when making the requests,
we get a response back as
soon as--successful response.
We're gonna actually make use
of a Python library
for dealing with srt files.
That makes it very easy
to manipulate them,
so SubRipFile and
we load it from this string.
And what gets returned
from this HTTP request
is really just the srt data
as a string.
So it's very easy to load
that into this object.
So the next portion of the code
is kind of Pig Latin-ification.
So now that we have
the data available and loaded
into memory,
we can perform
the steps needed to turn it
into Pig Latin.
For those not familiar
with, I guess, the concept
of Pig Latin, you take
the first letter
of a word,
and, if it's a consonant,
you move it to the end
and you add -ay after it.
If the first letter is a vowel,
then you just leave that alone,
but add -way to the end.
So my particular code
does not use
a very sophisticated
Pig Latin algorithm.
If you have any production
processes that depend
on, like, really rigid Pig Latin
completely to specification,
I do not recommend that you take
a look at my code and copy that.
But for this particular purpose,
I think everything's fine,
so, you know,
the basic idea is, you know,
"Thank you for reading this"
would be "Hanktay youway orfay
eadingray histay."
So it's gonna do that.
It's actually looping.
I'm not showing this code
that's gonna loop
through each
of the different items
within the overall
caption track.
It's going to keep
the time codes in place.
We're not changing that.
But it's just going to translate
the actual text.
And the final step,
once we've done that,
we have this loaded
in memory somewhere,
we want to push that
back out to YouTube
using the upload capability
of the Captions API.
So there are
a few specific steps
that need to be done for this.
You need to set a content-type
header in your HTTP request
to a specific string,
which we have documented.
You have to set
the content language to--
content-language header
to the ICL language code
of the language corresponding
to the caption track
you're uploading.
There is no ICL language code
for Pig Latin
for some reason,
so I'm just gonna use English.
And I have that hard-coded
in my Script.
And there's a header
called a slug,
which represents the title
of your captions track.
And I have that hard-coded
as well.
So once we have
those headers set up,
we again create just the URL by
plugging in the ID of the video,
and we're going to make
a post request in this case.
We've previously been doing
get requests,
'cause
we've been retrieving data.
Just, you know,
in REST-ful APIs
when you want
to create something,
you normally will make
a post request.
So we're doing a post request,
we are setting the body
of the request
to be equal
to the translated captions body.
And we're using those headers
that we defined before.
So that's the relevant portions
of the code.
I want to show you
the code in action.
You don't really see
too much going on here.
But hopefully this is somewhere
in my history.
Here we go.
And this is also making use
of the stored credentials
that I have from a previous time
that I run the code,
so I have my OAuth 2 credentials
already saved somewhere.
I don't have
to authenticate again.
So this will run.
Captions are
successfully transmitted.
And if I go back
to this video...
Okay, we should be able
to select not English.
Pig Latin.
It is now listed as one
of the captions tracks, so I
think that's selected right now.
Hey, Zack.
This is my first day.
Yes.
There we go.
Okay, so, you know,
it's that much more
of a meaningful moment
when it's in Pig Latin.
[laughter]
I assure you.
Okay, so that's one example.
Here's another example.
I'm not gonna go
through all the code for this,
but I wanted
to just show this to you,
and you could take a look
at the code later,
and you could actually use this
at something
that's fully deployed
to App Engine right now,
and you might find it
useful for your own purposes.
So this is actually
an application that I wrote
in response to talking
to Naomi,
and Naomi,
among other things,
is responsible
for providing captions
for the many, many videos
that get uploaded
that are associated with Google.
Black: Several hundred.
Several hundred sessions
from I/O hit--hit our channel,
like, this week.
Posnick: Exactly.
Black: And we need
to caption them.
Posnick: Yes.
So we need to provide those
captions for our own videos.
And if you were
to do that manually
using the YouTube Web interface,
it's certainly possible,
but it would take
quite a bit of time.
You would have to do one track
at a time more or less.
And that obviously multiplies
out across hundreds of videos.
It's quite a bit of work.
Black: It's horrible.
Nobody should have to do that.
Posnick: Fair enough.
And nobody has to.
Thanks
to the YouTube Captions API,
we're able to automate all that.
So I have this over here.
This is something that also
would require authentication
because we're gonna be creating
caption tracks,
so first thing I'll do
is add my account.
Excuse me.
And this is using AuthSub
for authentication.
It's not actually using OAuth 2,
but it's something
conceptually very similar.
Since I'm already signed in,
all I have to click
is "allow access"...
[coughs]
and I'll be able to grant
my application the ability
to upload tracks.
So at this point,
now that I've authenticated,
it knows who I am,
and I can select local files.
Let me get this
from the desktop.
So I have
three caption tracks here.
The name of the caption track
is actually important.
'Cause we just,
as a way of saving time,
we read the video ID from
the name of the caption track,
and we also read
the language code.
So you can see these all
are video ID-underscore-
language code,
and, if you wanted to,
you could also put in the name
of the caption track here
as well.
So now that I've selected
those three files--
and you can select
an arbitrary number of files.
It can be for a bunch
of different videos.
It doesn't all have to be
for the same video.
Quick click, start upload...
and what you should see
is that these caption tracks
are being pushed out.
It's using the YouTube API.
This is actually Java code
running on App Engine.
And it's talking to the YouTube
API a very similar way
to what we previously covered.
And you get back actually using
the Channel API in App Engine.
We get back a response
from the server
to our browser saying,
"Okay, all these three things
were a success."
If any of these caption tracks,
you know,
were badly formatted
or there were any other errors,
you know, we'd find out
about that right away
as well,
and we could, you know,
take appropriate action.
So now that that's been
completed, we should be able
to go back to our video.
Reload this one more time.
And we have the caption tracks
listed here,
so in addition
to our Pig Latin track,
I just uploaded English,
you know, Hebrew, and Italian.
And this doesn't actually
correspond to the text
in the video,
but, you know,
just showing you
what you can do.
So that's, as I mentioned,
available
just as an open-source project.
Take a look at the code,
adapt it to anything
that you might find, you know,
useful for your own project,
or just use the yt-captions-
uploader.appspot.com instance
just for uploading captions
to your videos.
So we're ready at this point
for question and answers.
Just a reminder again,
if you're tweeting
about this session,
you can use those hashtags.
And if you want
to provide feedback,
you could go
to that particular link.
Black: And I forgot
to put it on this slide,
but you can also email
captioning@google.com.
So thanks, guys.
Does anybody have any questions
you want to ask us
about any of this stuff?
If you could come up to the mic.
woman: Hi. Hi.
Black: Hi.
woman: I have to close-caption
my own video,
so I have to do it manually.
I don't have--
right, I am the creator
of the script itself,
and I've attempted
to use the built-in captioning
from YouTube,
and it's gotten better,
right,
but I'd be curious of your plans
about increasing
the accuracy of that file,
because I work
at community college,
and I create a lot of video
for students studying
Web development,
but even at that level,
I have to close-caption it
for the district requirements.
So I'm curious, where--what's
the state of that function?
You understand
what I'm asking?
Black: Yeah. So there's
actually--there's two features
in YouTube, and I think people
sometimes confuse the two,
so I'll explain them both.
There's auto-captioning, which
is pure machine-made captions,
and it sounds like
what you're doing is you log in
as the owner, you download
the machine-made caption track,
you edit it, clean it up,
and then you re-upload it
to make good, solid,
accurate captions.
So that's one way to do it.
The other way to do it
is also what we're doing
actually at I/O.
We have the transcription
in all the keynotes
that's providing
the live-streamed captions.
At the end of the day,
yesterday, I got a bunch
of text files, and I take
that text file,
I log into the channel,
I upload it,
and I use speech recognition
to synchronize it.
And that's an easier task
for a computer,
'cause it doesn't have to guess
what all of those
technical terms are.
As long as it can fix
a few points in there,
it can align it
very accurately in time.
So for most of my videos,
especially the technical ones,
what I tend to do is I prepare
a plain-text transcript,
and then I upload the transcript
to YouTube
and use the speech recognition
that way.
So you can use both methods.
But to get back
to your other question
about the accuracy
and will it improve, absolutely.
We've improved our word error
rate this year--
I forget the exact number.
We put it in a blog post,
and then
I immediately forgot it,
but if you go look,
there's a blog post on it.
One of the cool things
about YouTube is,
as people are uploading captions
to YouTube,
we can use that text
and those videos
to make our algorithms better.
And so over time
we hope to improve the quality,
and we are definitely working
on it.
But YouTube
is sort of a vast corpus.
You have everything
from people recording videos
in their bedroom to, you know,
stuff like I/O.
And so solving that is a hard
and really interesting problem.
woman: Yeah.
And I'm working on making--
since there's nobody
behind me,
I hope it's okay that
I ask another question.
Black: Go for it.
woman: Is that,
I've worked on making
the audio quality better
so that the accuracy improves
because of that,
because I'm the sole provid--
I mean, I'm the only one.
I don't have people
standing there, you know,
sitting there,
doing that,
so I'm glad to hear--
I knew it was,
but I was just curious
about what--
I hadn't heard
the efficiency numbers,
so I'll go look for those
as well.
'Cause our--you know,
what we call
our people that are responsible
for saying,
"Yes, we're closed-captioned,"
are looking at those numbers
on ours and going,
"That's not good enough."
Black: Yeah, I mean,
I would agree with them.
What we do on our own videos,
we leave
the automatic captions on
for all the videos,
and actually the owner
of the channel
actually has the option
to turn this off.
So sometimes if you see
a video that's in English,
and you think, "Hey,
this should have worked.
Why don't I have the option
to transcribe audio?",
it may be because the owner
has turned it off.
But if you're the owner
and you leave it on,
and we do this
for all of our Google channels,
we leave it on
because sometimes we don't get
the captions up immediately.
And we want to provide something
in the interim
that helps people to understand
what has been said.
But we still follow up
with a professionally-produced
caption file
where we really were sure
that the text is accurate
because we feel like there's
still too big a gap.
We don't want--you know,
if you're hearing
and you're watching it,
you can tell when there's a
mistake, but if you were deaf,
you wouldn't know,
and so we want to be sure
that it's really accurate.
Although we hope that, you know,
in the future,
we'll be able to just let it go,
and it'll be automated,
but we're not there yet.
woman: Yeah, that's the--
the amount I have to do
is the real--
is the real key.
Thank you.
Black: Cool.
Any other questions?
Come on up to the mic.
man: Hi. Is there any
interest in standardizing it?
I mean, not only Google TV
and YouTube,
but regular TV networks.
Black: Umm, I'm not sure
I understand your question.
Can you ask it...
man: Uh, okay.
If in the future,
you think this is the technology
that it's gonna rule,
I mean, the--
the regular closed captions
and stuff?
Black: You mean,
do I think that, in the future
we'll have closed captions
on everything?
man: That's right.
This technology's
gonna be the one
that is gonna rule
closed-captioning.
Black: I think for technology
to be really widely adopted
for closed-captioning,
there are two pieces.
One, the people
who are creating the content
have to see value
in the captioning.
They have to want
to add the captions.
But the second part of it,
which I think also affects
the first
is how easy it is to do.
And I'm really excited
about some of the changes
that are coming in HTML5
because I think
they're going to make it easier
and easier
for anyone to add captions
to their content,
so whether, you know,
you're a big TV broadcaster--
and the line between TV and the
Web is getting blurred, right?
We have shows that we watch
online, and we have shows
that we watch on our television.
And with Google TV,
you can be watching them both
at the same time.
I think as we move forward, we
will see more and more captions
on this content because
it's becoming easier to do
and also because our audiences
are more global,
more international.
man: Thank you.
man 2: This is kind
of a logistical question.
I work at a university, and I
know a lot of our professors
would prefer
to keep their videos
hosted in the Docs section
of Google.
I know that that's powered,
you know, by the YouTube engine.
Do the same APIs--can they
be used with those videos?
Black: I am so happy
you asked this question.
We've only been talking
about YouTube,
but we actually have a product
that's part of Google Apps,
and it's called
Video for Business.
And Google Video for Business
is kind of going
through a transition period
where we're getting ready
to launch the new hotness,
so right now,
if you're an Apps customer
and you're using video,
you actually have two internal
video hosting tools.
You have Google Video
for Business, which allows you
to post captions,
and you can even do
the speech recognition
transcript synchronization
in Video for Business,
and all of those are private
to your domain
and hosted in the cloud.
The new hotness that's coming
is basically you'll be able
to just upload a video file
as part of Docs.
So the same way that you would
upload an image file
or a document and Google Docs
would store it for you
and let you share it
with people,
you'd be able to upload a video,
and you can just play the video
right there in Docs,
and that video player in Docs
needs to have captions.
And it needs to have an API that
lets you interact with them.
We're still building that out,
but, in the future,
that's something
that I think a lot
of our enterprise customers
are gonna need,
and we're definitely focusing
on it.
man 2: And then
my second question is,
is there any plan--
we have this great method
of uploading these captions--
to then allow--
you've put
those captions up there
and then automatically translate
so that you don't have
to go through the second step
of, you know,
pulling your text back up
and then using the API
to put it back up
as another language file?
Black: So I'm sorry,
I don't think
I understood the question.
Try that again a different way.
man 2: I'm sorry,
so is there any plans,
if you have existing tracks,
captioning tracks
that you've put up there,
to automatically allow users
to then translate them
to another language?
Black: Oh, we have that now
in YouTube.
Can we pop up YouTube?
I'll show you quickly.
Posnick: I can drive that.
Black: Pop up YouTube.
Posnick: So let's hit
and choose...
something over here?
Translate captions I believe...
Black: So in order for translate
to work in YouTube,
you just have to have
a caption track in any language.
It probably works best
if you start with English,
'cause we just have
a lot more data for English.
But you can translate
to any 1 of 57 languages.
That's how we're doing
the caption gadget today.
It's machine translation
using translate.google.com,
and it's built
right into YouTube.
man 2: And that's even if it's
captions that you've uploaded?
So the user would select your
set of captions and then be able
to translate using that
second list that's underneath?
Black: Right.
I mean, Jeff's example showed
using the speech recognition
mostly because we wanted
to cram everything
into one example
that people could then pull off
and use it to write other code.
But you would--most of the time,
you would just use
your regular English track
to do that,
and his example was kind of,
"Well, what if there's
a language that's not in there,"
so that's
how we added Pig Latin.
man 2: Awesome.
Black: Does that make sense?
man 2: Thank you.
Black: Okay.
I think we have time
for one,
maybe two more questions.
man 3: Hi, there.
Have you had to work
with any standards that
the variety of screen readers
might have in order
to read captions?
Black: So standards--you mean
standards for the file format?
man 3: Yeah, we have standards
for producing media,
and then I think there might be
some standards
for the screen readers
to actually read things
within the media.
Black: So I'm not--
there may be
that I'm not aware of.
I've only really started looking
at audio description recently
as we've been putting
more of our video on the Web
and realizing that we wanted
to find a way
to make it available
to blind users.
And on the Web today,
really the only way to do it,
unless you have
a very specialized player
that you've built,
is to record a wav file
and mix it into your video.
And so in this case what
the screen reader is getting
is it's just getting
text instructions
through the accessibility API
that tells it what to read.
So I don't know that there's
a specialized format.
I mean, it has to be a format
that's compatible
with your browser, I guess,
but it's actually pretty simple.
man 3: Good. I think
that's the overall problem,
is that there are
so many choices for, you know,
JAWS and Window-Eyes,
things like that,
that can be OS-level or
even specific like ChromeVox.
Black: Yeah, I mean,
you as the content creator
or the page creator
or the video hoster,
you shouldn't have to worry
about any of that.
Your browser should know
how to do it for you.
man 3: Okay, thanks.
Black: Okay, anybody else,
or should we let the hordes in
for the next talk?
Let's let the hordes in.
Thank you so much.
[applause]